[Music]
we learned four properties of metals in
our earlier video
can you name them for me metallic luster
malleability ductility and that they are
hard these were the four properties
right can you think of some more
properties of metals metal utensils are
used for cooking unpay why do you think
they're used for this purpose which
energy do we need to cook food heat
energy correct we need heat energy to
cook food and metal utensils are good
conductors of heat they help transfer
heat evenly through the entire surface
and provide even heating no doubt most
metals are known to be good conductors
of heat do you know the two best
conductors of heat they are silver and
copper two are the metals like lead and
Mercury are comparatively poor
conductors of heat electric via swill so
made up of metals right why is that it's
because they are good conductors of
electricity too if we have a battery and
a bulb connected in a circuit with a
metal wire you will see that the bulb
will glow where the switch is closed and
because they are good conductors of
electricity they are coated with rubber
like material this rubber-like material
acts as an insulator which protects us
from being electrocuted if we touch the
wire by mistake do you know any other
property of metals what happens when we
strike a metal on a hard surface like
you tells us banging against the sink
can you hear a sound produced by metal
yes this is another property of metals
we can call metals as sonorous meaning
they produce sound when hit against a
hot surface no doubt school bells
church bells or the bells in a temple
are made up of metals if these are the
characteristics of metals what do you
think will be the characteristics of
nonmetals in simple words just the
opposite of metals
in a nutshell nonmetals like carbon
iodine or sulfur do not have lustre they
do not shine and are brittle in nature
what do we mean by brittle they cannot
be beaten into sheets or wires as most
of them turn into powder when hit by a
hard substance nonmetals can also be
gases like oxygen hydrogen or solids
like carbon sulfur etc do you know of
any nonmetal in the liquid state bromine
is the only nonmetal which is in the
liquid state nonmetals do not conduct
heat or electricity and they do not
produce that sound when hit against a
hard surface this means that they do not
have the property of sonority so isn't
it easy and simple to differentiate
between metals and nonmetals only on the
basis of their physical properties wait
but mercury is a metal in liquid state
at room temperature and bromine is a
nonmetal in a liquid state at room
temperature how do we differentiate
between the two based on physical
properties we can say that all metals
are solids at room temperature
except mercury and all nonmetals are
either solid or gaseous except bromine
well this is not it there are a few more
exceptions that break the physical
appearance norms of metals and nonmetals
for example most metals have high
melting point which means that they need
a large amount of heat to melt but look
at the two metals gallium and cesium
they melt when you keep them on your
palm we must say then that these two
metals have a very low melting point
look at another exception in nonmetals
iodine for example is the nonmetal but
it has a property of the metals can you
point out which property I'm talking
about
correct the luster iodine has shine or
luster which is technically the property
of metals take another example carbon
for
instance what does carbon is it a metal
or nonmetal yes carbon is a non-metal
but look at diamond or graphite they all
come from carbon they are known as
allotropes the different forms in which
carbon can exist are called its
allotropes let us look at the allotrope
diamond of carbon it is known as the
hardest substance and has an extremely
high melting point and boiling point
aren't these the properties of metals
but it is surprising that diamond is an
allotrope of carbon which is nonmetal
diamond 2 is a nonmetal which strongly
exhibits the properties of metals now
that we know of so many exceptions do
you think it's easy to differentiate
between metals and nonmetals based on
their physical properties I doubt that
but don't worry there is another way out
of this it is to differentiate the two
based on that chemical properties how is
that done for that you will have to
watch our next lesson
you